En el último video hicimos algunos ejemplos
donde teníamos un dígito que se repetía
por siempre y por siempre y por siempre...
y fuimos capaces de convertirlos en fracciones.
En este video quiero abordar algo un poco
más interesante que son varios número repitiéndose
una y otra vez por siempre.
Digamos por ejemplo que tenemos el número
0....0.36 barra.
Esto... ¿esto qué significa?
Pues nuevamente que 36 se va a estar repitiendo
una y otra y otra y otra vez para siempre...
muy bien, entonces tendremos 0.363636...
y así sucesivamente, nunca va a acabar.
Y entonces vamos a utilizar la misma técnica,
vamos a llamarle a este número,
una variable "x", muy bien. Entonces, el detalle es multiplicar por alguna potencia de 10,
digamos por 10, 100, 1000
o qué se yo...
de tal suerte que podamos alinear los .363636
que se repiten por siempre, entonces si nosotros
movemos dos unidades, dos espacios el número
decimal, vamos a poder hacerlo,
entonces necesitamos multiplicar por 100 que es 10 al cuadrado verdad.
Entonces si multiplicamos esto por 100, lo que vamos a tener es que este número se recorre
dos espacios y tenemos 36.3636...
y así sucesivamente, muy bien.
Entonces, vamos ahora a restarle "x" como
lo hicimos en el video anterior.
Restamos "x" y entonces será lo mismo que
restar 0.3636... y así sucesivamente
y hacemos la cuenta.
Vamos a ver...
"100x" menos "x" nos quedan, "99x", muy bien, 100 de algo menos 1 de ese algo
pues me quedan 99 de ese algo y ahora, si restamos esto, todos estos se van a cancelar
con estos de aquí, son exactamente igual y nos queda solo 36, muy bien.
Entonces "x", si dividimos de ambos lados entre 99, lo que nos queda es que esto se cancelan
y me queda que "x" es igual a 36 entre 99
y como bueno podemos ver
entre qué son divisibles ambos verdad, y 36 es divisible entre 9 y 99 también, así que dividimos
entre 9 de ambos lados...
arriba y abajo y nos queda, 36 entre 9 es 4,
verdad, 9 por 4 son 36 y 99 entre 9 es 11,
así que este número el .363636...
es 4/11, fue un número muy sencillo.
Vamos a hacer otro ejemplo,
digamos que tengo ahora yo el número, "x" igual a 0.714 barra, pero ahora el que se repite solo es el 14, ok.
Esto en términos más prácticos es 0.7141414...
y así sucesivamente, verdad.
Entonces, ahora, nosotros tenemos que multiplicar
por algo de tal suerte que se alineen y a
lo mejor tú estarías tentado a multiplicar
por 1000 verdad, recorrerlo hasta acá, pero
si tu lo haces de esa forma no se van a alinear,
no se van a alinear.
Así que vamos a multiplicar,
nuevamente por 100 y verás que aquí si se anulan...
si se alinean perdón...
entonces si multiplicamos por 100, vamos a
recorrer este punto dos espacios
y vamos a tener 71.41414... y así
sucesivamente, verdad.
Entonces, restamos la "x", restamos "x" como siempre y entonces en realidad restamos 0.71414...
y así sucesivamente,
¿viste que ahora sí se alinearon en este caso? ok.
Entonces, otra vez, vamos a restar y tenemos 100 de algo menos 1 de ese algo,
pues tenemos 99 de ese algo, muy bien.
Y si restamos, aquí los que se cancelan son estos a partir de este momento
y ahora tenemos  que restar 71.4 menos 0.7.
Entonces, aquí lo que podemos hacer es digamos,
pedimos prestado verdad, éste se convierte
en un 14 y éste se convierte en un 0.
Entonces 7 para acá...
o 14 menos 7 es 7, va el punto decimal
y ahora tenemos 70 menos 0, son 70.
Y aquí a lo mejor tú dices,
"oye están pasando cosas muy raras porque me quedo un número decimal aquí y yo lo quiero en fracciones",
bueno, vamos a seguir el procedimiento
y ahorita lo corregimos.
Entonces, si dividimos entre 99 de ambos lados,
me queda que "x", verdad...
estos se cancelan y que "x" va a ser 70.7 entre 99.
Entonces lo que voy a hacer es, multiplicar
arriba y abajo, en el numerador y en el denominador
por alguien de tal forma que este punto decimal
se me recorra, entonces en realidad si yo
multiplico por 10 arriba y por 10 abajo, verdad... si te das cuenta aquí fue como multiplicar por 1
y multiplicar por 1 al número no le hace nada, sin embargo lo que vamos a hacer es que el numerador
quede expresado sin punto decimal y abajo también.
Entonces, si multiplicamos estos dos nos queda,
707 entre 900....
perdón 99 por 10, que son 990, muy bien.
Entonces ya tenemos la solución.
Vamos a hacer uno más.
Digamos que ahora tenemos el número,
"x" igual a 3.257 y el 257 es periódico,
es decir, éste se repite.
Entonces, volvemos a hacer el mismo truco,
podemos multiplicar por algo de tal suerte
que al restarlo se alineen y en este caso
pues coincide muy bien con el 1000.
1000 veces este "x", va a ser...
ehhh... va a ser...
este se recorre tres lugares verdad, 1, 2, 3...
y entonces me queda 3257.257257257...
y así sucesivamente, muy bien.
Entonces ahora sí, restamos "x", si le restamos
la "x", en realidad estamos restando...
hay que alinear el punto decimal...
estamos restando 3.257257257... y así sucesivamente,
verdad, le estamos restando esto...
acá me falto ponerle que le estamos restando,
muy bien.
Entonces, ¿qué es lo que me queda?
Si yo tengo 1000 de algo y le resto 1, pues
nos quedan 999 de ese algo
y si aquí restamos esto, si nos damos cuenta, estos se cancelan con todo estos y simplemente me queda,
3257 menos 3 y que esos son, 3254, muy bien.
Entonces, finalmente ya podemos ver quien es "x", porque "x" será,
si dividimos entre 999 de ambos lados, nos queda que "x" es 3254 entre 999, muy bien.
Entonces, ahora podemos darnos cuenta
de que este número...
esta fracción es impropia y si es impropia podemos dividir y ver...
cuantos... cuantas... cuantos enteros tiene, digamos, cual es su parte entera...
Entonces, digo, también podrías hacerlo de otras formas, por ejemplo,
decir que "x" es 3 más 0.257 que se repite,
ver cuanto es eso y demás,
pero bueno vamos, vamos a
hacerlo de esta forma, vamos a dividir...
tenemos 3254 entre 999 y esto va a caber 3 veces...
va a caber 3 veces, verdad...
Pues sí, más o menos cabe tres veces.
Entonces 3 por 9 son 27 y llevamos 2, 3 por
9 son 27 y le sumamos estos dos, son 29
y llevamos otros 2, 3 por 9 son 27 y 2 son 29
y ahora lo restamos...
lo restamos...
y tenemos ehhh... 4 es más chico que 7 entonces
éste se convierte en un 14 y éste se convierte
en un 4 y 14 menos 7, nos queda 7,
ahora tenemos que 4 hay que restarle 9, éste es más chico entonces le pedimos prestado 1 al de la izquierda,
se vuelve 1 y tenemos 14 - 9, son 5... son 5, ahora tenemos 1 menos 9, otra vez es más chico,
entonces éste se convierte en
11 porque le pide prestado 1 al 3
y entonces 11 menos 9 son 2 y ahora nos queda 2 menos 2 son 0 y ya tenemos nuestra respuesta
porque esto simplemente será 3 enteros con 257/999.